اهلا بكم اخصصوا حلقه هذا الاسبوع من
البعد الاخر للعمل الانساني والاغاثه في
ضوء كارثه زلزال سوريا وتركيا كما سننتهز
المناسبه لتسليط الضوء على الوضع في
اوكرانيا مع مرور سنه على اندلاع الحرب
فيها وايضا على الوضع في افغانستان
وفلسطين استضيف في الجزء الاكبر من هذه
الحلقه نائب رئيس اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر للكربونيه ورئيس صندوق اغاثه اطفال
فلسطين ستيف
انا منتهى الرمحي احييكم اينما كنتم من
العربيه هذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
واسمحوا لي ان ارحب بنائب رئيس اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر السيد جيل
الكربونيه اهلا بك معنا ضيف في الاستوديو
في البعد الاخر واسمح لي ان ابدا معك
بالسؤال عن تعاملكم مع زلزال وكارثه سوريا
تركيا اين تضعون هذا الزلزال في الكوارث
الطبيعيه
كارثه بيتم معنى الكلمه طبعا نحن نتعاطف
مع الضحايا والناجين واسرهم ما قمنا به
لجنه دوليه لصليب الاحمر هو الاستجابه
فورا يوم الاثنين الماضي قبل اسبوع من
خلال تقديم المساعدات الطبيه للمستشفى في
حلب وكذلك
الافرشه والبطانيات للناجين
وكذلك تقديم المياه والمستلزمات الاساسيه
نتعاون مع الهلال الاحمر السوري وفي تركيا
فان الهلال الاحمر التركي هو في مقدمه
الاستجابه الانساني هل هناك ايه اولويات
في حسب المنطقه الجغرافيه في سوريا او في
تركيا كيف تتعاملون مع مع هذه الازمه يعني
شرحت لنا حضرتك كيف
احب الصلي احمر من دول اليوم الثاني
للكارثه
للملاحقه لكن هل هناك ايه
اولوياتنا هي انقاذ الحيه فورا وتخفيف
المعاناه ولكن ما نعلمه هو انه في سوريا
هذه الازمه جاءت لتنضم الى ازمتين
متواجدتين منذ سنوات حاولنا ان نوفر
الحمايه ونساعد المجتمعات في سوريا بسبب
الصراع وقد تضررت من ذلك وكذلك
بتردي الاقتصاد وعدم الوصول الى الخدمات
الاساسيه نرى ان نصف الامدادات المياه لا
تعمل جيدا وفي ديسمبر تفشى وباء الكوليرا
اذا نحن نسعى لتجنب تفشي لوباء الكوليرا
من جديد من خلال توفير المياه الصالحه
للشرب وكذلك مستلزمات النظافه ما نركز
عليه هو انه حتى قبل الزلزال
المجتمع على الصمود كانت ضعيفه للغايه
والاحتياجات الاساسيه كانت على شفافه
الانهيار وبالتالي هذه ازمه جاءت لتفاق
معزمات اخرى وتضع سبل العيش للمجتمعات في
وضع بالغ الصعوبه الصحيح الازمه السياسيه
الكبيره في سوريا الى اي مدى تعطل عملكم
كعمل انساني وعمل اغاثه سواء في موضوع
الزلزال او موضوع الكوليرا او موضوع
المشردين والمهجرين والنازحين من بيوتهم
كيف تقومون بعملكم في ظل وجود هذا الصراع
الداخلي السوري
لدينا المئات من الزملاء الذين يعملون في
سوريا وقد عملوا هناك على مدار السنوات
بالتعاون مع هيئه الهلال الاحمر السوري
وفي الوقت ذاته وفي ظل الاوضاع الراهنه
نرى انه امر اساسي ان لا يتم تسييس
المساعدات الانسانيه او استخدامها كاداه
حتى يستطيع المحتاج في اي مكان كانوا من
تلقي المساعدات الضروريه اذا نحن
تعاوننا مع كافه الاطراف ذات العلاقه
لضمان توفير المساعدات وينبغي ان اقول
ايضا اننا شاهدنا تضامنا عالميا على نطاق
واسع الحقيقه سيد لستم الوحي دون الذين
يطالبون بضروره عدم تسييس العمل الاغاثي
والانساني لكن في سوريا واضح انه السيس
يعني كان في تعطيل من كل الجهات لوصول
العمليات الانقاذ كيف بتواجهوا هذه الازمه
كيف بتحلوها
نحن منظمه انسانيه وبالتالي لا نخوض في اي
اعتبارات اوجد سياسي نحن ما نقوم به هو
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه وفي الاوضاع
التي يحتاج فيها الناس الوصول الى مساعدات
حيويه نقوم بالتعاون مع كافه الاطراف ذات
الع لضمان تسليم المساعدات وهذا ما نقوم
به في الوقت الراهن رئيسنا
زارا سوريا خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
ونحن نتعاون مع كافه الاطراف على اساس هذا
المبدا المبدا الانساني الذي ينبغي
للاطفال والنساء والكبار السن ان يحصلوا
على المساعدات التي هم بامسه الحاجه لديها
لها ولدينا الوسائل للقيام لذلك كون نرى
هذا السخاء الكبير في العالم وهذا ما نعمل
عليه في الوقت الراح لا شك بانكم تقومون
بما تستطيعون في حل هذه الازمه الانسانيه
والاغاثيه لا اقصد الازمه السياسيه لكن
عندما تقول بانه رئيس صليب الاحمر كان في
سوريا كان في جهه النظام السوري ولا في
جهه المعارضه السوريه واذا ذهبت مساعدات
للنظام السوري يقال بانها لا تذهب
للمعارضه والعكس صحيح من هنا تاتي هذه
الازمه في غاثه المنكوبين
الكثير من المناطق في سوريا وقد تعاونت مع
السلطات وما نلاحظه اننا نحاول بانفسنا
تقييم الاحتياجات على الارض وعلى هذا
الاساس نقدم استجابه لكننا متواجدون هناك
ايضا عدت الى المساعده التي قدمناها
لمستشفى حلب لا نقوم بذلك مره واحده وانما
نعود الى مستشفى لنتاكد من المساعدات وصلت
الى المحتاجين اليها من
المصابين ومن اجل ذلك نحتاج للوصول وهذا
دائما ما نناقشه مع كافه الاطراف ذات
العلاقه حتى نحصل على الوصول لتقديم
المساعدات لمن يحتاج اليها
تستطيعون برغم العراقيل ان تقدموا مساعدات
هناك اثار هذا الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا هل
تتوقع انه ستنتهي في المستقبل القريب بناء
على خبرتكم وتجربتكم يعني
[موسيقى]
بشان الاوضاع في سوريا وهذا امر مهم لانه
شهدناه العام الماضي هو الكثير من
الاهتمام بالاوضاع في اوكرانيا واحيانا
ربما اهتمام اقل بشان الاستجابه الاوضاع
في سوريا وفغانستان وافريقيا ومن المهم
حشد المجتمع الدولي في هذه الظروف حتى يتم
تجاهل احتياجات اشخاص هم فيها مصر الحاجه
اليها عندما تغيب وسائل الاعلام عنه ما
يحدث الان هو اننا نستطيع ان نصلت الضوء
على الحاجه للاستثمار في الحفاظ على
الانظمه المياه صالحه للشرب وشبكات
الكهرباء والقطاع الصحي في الحاله جيده
للملايين من السوريين وهذه فرصه
لاعاده ت
ان هذا ما عملنا عليه خلال السنوات
الماضيه هناك حاجه للمزيد لاننا نرى ان
الكثير من الانظمه هي على حافه الانهيار
هذا على المستوى العام يعني المنظور العام
كيفيه انقاذ
السكان في سوريا المواطنين السوريين الان
بعزال راينا صور كثيره ترددت اطفال فقدوا
اهلي اهلهم اطفال اصبحوا مشردين بلا ماوى
بلا مكان هل لديكم اي خطه لهذا الملف
خطه بهذا الصدد نحاول مساعده الاطفال ولا
سيما الاطفال الذين فقدوا اهاليهم باعتبار
ذلك اولويه لانهم في اوضاع هشه للغايه
نعمل كذلك بالتعاون مع المتطوعين على
الارض من خلال الهلال الاحمر السوري ولكن
نرى ايضا ان هناك
مفقودون احيانا
الاباء والامهات وكذلك الاطفال يكونون
مفقودين ويمكن للاسرا تتصل بمكتبنا وتقدم
طلبا لتعقب بهؤلاء المفقودين ونبذل قصار
جهدنا بتعاون مع الشركاء لاعطاء اجوبه على
هذه الاسئله تتصودين مدى الالم الذي يشعر
به اولئك الذين يفقدون احبائهم ونحاول ان
نلم الشتاته مصر المشتته هذه الكارثه
الطبيعيه الحقيقه اخذت الاضواء على
المستوى الاخباري من كارثه اخرى تقع في
العالم الان الحرب في اوكرانيا مر سنه على
هذه الحرب ما هو تقييمكم للوضع الانساني
هناك او في ظل هذه الحرب
انه عندما تنظرين الى اوكرانيا الارقام
تتحدث عن نفسها لدينا ثمانيه ملايين
اوكراني لجاوا الى الخارج وحوالي 6 ملايين
نزحوا من ديارهم وهناك حوالي 17 مليون شخص
بحاجه للمساعده الانسانيه في اوكرانيا
الوضع بالغ الصعوبه ونحن متواجدون هناك
نتعاون ايضا مع الصليب الاحمر الاوكراني
وهناك امر مهم للغايه حتى يتم التخفيف من
المعاناه وهو احترام القانون الانساني
الدولي
الاتفاقيات التي تحمي العمل الانسان يجب
ان تسري وينبغي احترام هذه الاتفاقيات
وتطبيقها نحن في اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر نحن مفوضون للدفاع
والمطالبه باحترام القانون الانساني
الدولي وهذا هو السبب الذي يجعلنا نتعاون
مع السلطات في وكذلك في روسيا بشان ضروره
التقيد
بالقانون الانساني الدولي لحمايه المدنيين
وكذلك البنيه التحتيه المدنيه علاوه على
حمايه
السجناء الحرب او المعتقلين من المدنيين
هل هناك اولويات محدده بالنسبه للتعامل مع
الوضع في اوكرانيا بالنسبه لكم يعني شيء
يكون في القمه يعني تحاولون حله او اول
الاشياء
لدينا اولويه خلال فصل الشتاء الراهن الا
وهي ضمان ان اكثر الناس ضعفا ان يكون
لديهم ماوى وسبل الحصول على التدفئه في
شهرين يناير وفبراير ولكن لدينا اولويات
اخرى الا وهي تقديم الدعم
فيتعلق بالمس
البلديات لتقديم المياه الصالحه للشرب
والكهرباء
للمستشفيات حتى تواصل هذه الانظمه عملها
هذه اولويه عملنا عليها بتعاون مع
البلديات والسلطات المسؤوله وهناك مسؤوليه
اخرى الا وهي
التعاون مع السلطات لحمايه المدنيين
والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه وفقا للقانون
الانساني الدولي وكذلك اتفاقيات جونيف
الى الملف الطويل الحقيقه عشرات السنوات
ونحن نناقش بنفس الفكره
ونفس الملف والازمات الانسانيه داخل هذه
الدوله افغانستان الكثير من الناس
المحتاجين هناك الكثير من الالام المتفرقه
وللاسباب المتفرقه كيف تتعاملون مع شان
الافغاني
هي بلد
تعاملنا فيه مع الكثير من الازمات منذ
منتصف الثمانينات فالمحزن ان نقول اننا
نقدم ونوفر الحمايه لاجيال من الافغان
واحيانا نرى الاجداد الذين نقدم لهم
المساعده بعد تقديم المساعده
لابنائهم واحفادهم فهؤلاء اجيال من
الافغان يحصلون على المساعدات والوضع
الاقتصادي يتهاوى وما
ركزنا عليه منذ شهر اغسطس من عام 2021
فقد دعمنا حوالي ثلاثين مستشفى في
افغانستان من خلال تقديم رواتب
دكاتره والاطباء والممرضين ونواصل القيام
بذلك لان هذا امر حيوي بالنسبه للافغان
وكذلك يشمل عملنا
عمل اللجنه الدوليه لاساليب الاحمر
زياره السجناء ونواصل القيام بذلك كما
اننا نحاول بدل قصار جهدنا لتوفير سبل
العيش فان اجيال تعول على المساعدات
الانسانيه من
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر فلدينا
مبادره اقتصاديه تدعم الاشخاص للحصول على
سبل العيش الخاصه بهم للحصول ايضا على
كرامتهم هذه هي اولوياتنا ولكن ينبغي ان
اقول اننا نقوم بذلك في ظروف بالغه
الصعوبه في افغانستان لكن اننا الظالم
ملتزمين بمساعده الافغان موضوع المراه في
افغانستان ايضا موضوع حساس حرمانها من
الدراسه حرمانها من التعليم ومن العمل لكم
اي دور على هذا الصعيد
لقد عبرنا عن قلقنا بعد قرارات التي اتخذت
في اعقاب شهر ديسمبر من العام الماضي وما
قمنا به هو اننا تعاونا مع السلطات في
افغانستان لضمان ان كافه الموظفات يمكن
لهن ان تواصلنا عملهن كما فعلتنا من قبل
وهذا هو عليه الحال ومن جانب اخر نحن نحرس
على ضمان ان في المستشفيات التي ندعمها
وان في
المدارس التدريب
الطبي التي نمولها ان يكون هناك نساء ايضا
يعملن في هذه المؤسسات لانهم هذا امر مهم
لمستقبل افغانستان كما انها مساله اساسيه
اذا راغبنا في التعاون او التعامل مع
بطريقه تستند الى الاحتياجات ليس الا في
الكثير من الفتيات والكبيرات السن لديهن
احتياجات وهن تحتاج لمساعدات طبيه من قبل
النس نحن تعاوننا مع السلطات ونواصل ذلك
لضمان ان يظل الامر
السلطات تتجاوب معكم
والاناوه
ان نواصل العمل مع كافه موظفاتنا
عملنا معنا حتى الان وقد شهدنا ايضا انه
قدر المستطاع فان في المستشفيات والقطاع
الصحي الامر لله زال كذلك وهذا من اقوم به
بطريقه اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر نحن
نتبنى حوار بنا وسري مع كافه الاطراف
المعنيه وهذه طريقه عملنا في العالم باسره
نقوم بالعمل بشكل سري لضمان اننا نواصل
عملا الانساني وكذلك لنحمي قدر المستطاع
المدنيين الف شكر لك السيد جيل كربونيان
رئيس اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر على
مشاركتك معنا في هذا الجزء من البعد الاخر
شكرا جزيلا لك وبعد الفاصل لاتحدث واياكم
الى رئيس صندوق اغاثه اطفال فلسطين سوسيبل
ابقوا معنا
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
ونخصص هذا الجزء للعمل الانساني في فلسطين
واسمحوا لي ان استضيف رئيس منظمه اغاثه
اطفال فلسطين ستيفا سوسيبي ستيف كان صحفيا
امريكيا بارزا قرر ان يكرس حياته لاطفال
فلسطين واسس هذه المنظمه قبل عقود ليس هذا
فقط ستيف لكن اعتقد ايضا انه علاقتك
بفلسطين تتعدى ذلك ما هي علاقتك سر علاقتك
بفلسطين
لقد
[موسيقى]
ذهبت الى فلسطين خلال الانتفاضه الاولى
بصفه طالبا حصلت وقتها على فرصه ان اكون
ضمن بعثه حقوقيه الى جانب طلبات اخرين
لاعاين بنفسي الوضع في الضفه الغربيه وغزه
كانوا عرضه للقتل والسجن وكانت منازلهم
عرضه للتدمير ولكن في نفس الوقت كانوا
اناسا شجعانا جدا وبصفه اثارتني حيث انهم
كانوا على درجه كبيره من الانسانيه بما
جعلني مرتبطا جدا بهم على مستوى انساني
بحت
لقد شعرت بصفه امريكيا وبدرجه قويه بانه
علي
واجبه ومسؤوليه دعم الشعب الفلسطيني
وعندما عدت لاحقا واصبحت صحفيا واتولى
تغطيه الانتفاضه قبلت اطفالا اصيبوا ومنهم
من فقدوا رجولهم وكانوا بحاجه الى الرعايه
الطبيه
بدات بنقلهم الى مستشفيات امريكيه بالمجان
لقد وفرنا ذلك لاكثر من 2000 طفلا من
فلسطين ولكن ايضا من سوريا والعراق ومن
لبنان ولان نظهر لهم اننا نهتم لامرهم
واننا نحب اطفال فلسطين وانهم غير منسيين
وكنت متزوج بفلسطينيه
هدى كنت متزوجا من هدى المصري والدها من
القدس ووالدتها من رمل كنت اول امريكي
يتزوج لاجئه فلسطينيه داخل فلسطين اثناء
الانتفاضه كنا متزوجين لمده 17 عاما ثم
توفيت عام 2009 بالسرطان
متاسفه لسماع هذا الخبر لكن دعنا نتحدث
قليلا بشويه تفاؤل انت موجود الان في
الخليج لاطلاق مبادره جديده لدعم اطفال
فلسطين حدثني عن هذه المبادره
لمنطقه الخليج منذ 25 عاما اتي الى دبي
وكل الامارات العربيه المتحده للكويت وقطر
والبحرين والمملكه العربيه السعوديه على
مدار ربوع قرن وبفضل الدعم الذي تلقيناه
من هذه المنطقه من كل الجنسيات بمن فيهم
الاماراتيون والكويتيون والسعوديون انشانا
اقسام سرطان وعنايه مركزه وانقذنا حياه
عشرات الالاف من الاطفال فقط مؤخرا في رام
الله انهينا بناء مركزي عنايه مركزه مخصصا
للاطفال بفضل تبرعا من اسره كويتيه
والعام الماضي بنينا ايضا مركزا مماثلا
مخصصا للرضع في مستشفى الجنين بفضل اسره
اماراتي وانا هنا من اجل استمرار تدفق
الدعم لان الحاجه في فلسطين تتجاوز
مواردنا
نحن نؤمن بان توحيد الناس واظهار قيمه
العمل الذي سيتم القيام به وان حاجتنا
تحتاج اليهم وهم سيتجاوبون معنا
وسيساعدنا لو تخبرنا عن الوضع في فلسطين
خاصه انك يعني تعيش في رام الله وتتنقل من
رام الله بعد تجدد العنف خبرنا عن الوضع
هناك
انا اقيم واعمل في فلسطين على مدى اكثر من
ثلاثين عاما على مدى الانتفاضات وجل دورات
العنف التي شهدتها المنطقه
والازمه الحاليه تعد من الاسوء انها كذلك
ليس فقط لان الفلسطينيين مازالوا يموتون
يوميا وما زالت اراضيهم تنتزع منهم يوميا
ولكن ايضا واساسا لغياب الامل والافق الان
على مستوى سياسي سواء دوليا او حتى من
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه بل وحتى
الفلسطيني ولذلك ف بحاجه الى منظمات مثلنا
تهتم بحاجات الناس وتساعدهم على شؤونهم
الحياتيه واليوميه والضروريه تبدو الحا
واكثر ضروريه من اي وقت مضى ما هي اهم
الصعوبات التي تواجهكم في عملكم
نواجهه الكثير من الصعوبات واولها ان
حاجات الناس الذين نهتم بهم تفوق طاقتنا
ومواردنا مثل ما شرحت ذلك ما عنيته بذلك
هو ان هناك الاف الاطفال فالضفه الغربيه
بل العشرات الالاف بل ربما الملايين لهم
حاجات مختلفه في نفس الوقت يوجد في انحاء
اخرى من العالم ثروات كبيره وموارد عظيمه
وفقا لخبرتنا فان الناس في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا يرغبون بالقيام بعمل الخير لذلك ما
نرغب به هو ربط الصله بين اصحاب الخير ومن
هم محتاجون له بنقل الموارد من هذه
المنطقه ومن امريكا الشماليه لاننا منظمه
امريكيه وترجمه ذلك ضمن مبادرات وبرامج
تنقذ حياه الاطفال
هناك عدد كبير من الاطفال الفلسطينيين كما
تعلم موجودين في الاردن في لبنان في سوريا
في العراق في مناطق مختلفه بسبب عمليه
التهجير هل هؤلاء يشبهلهم عمل منظمتكم
ايضا ولا تركزون فقط على الاطفال داخل
فلسطين
ديار ديار
انهم مشمولون ببرامجنا ففي منظمتنا
ومنظمات اخرى نحن لا نميز المشمولين
بنشاطنا وفقا للغه او العرق او الديني او
اللون او الجنسيه اي طفل يحتاج سواء كان
لبنانيا اردنيا فلسطينيا عراقيا سواء كان
شيعيا او سنيا مسيحيا او مسلما تساعده
منظمتنا وفقا لحاجته لهيته او جنسيته وقد
ساعدنا للكثيرين من الاطفال ليس فقط
الفلسطينيين بل من العراق وسوريا ولبنان
والاردن وحتى مصر ودول اخرى لا تشمل فقط
الاطفال الفلسطينيين اما انما الاطفال في
اي مكان اخر
يشمل الاطفال من كل الجنسيه والخلفيات
بالطبع لدينا موارد محدوده ونحن نرى الان
هذه الماساه في تركيا وسوريا ونامل لو كان
لدينا الموارد الكافيه مثل تلك التي تتوفر
الى الامم المتحده بما يسمح لنا
بالاستجابه والتحرك للمشاركه في اعمال
الاغاثه والانقاذ
لو تحدثني عن خططكم المستقبليه مستقبلا
كيف ترون منظمتكم ماذا تريدون ما هو الهدف
الذي تريدون تحقيقه
منظمتنا مهيكله الان لتحديد حاجيات اطفال
فلسطين وايضا منطقه الشرق الاوسط مثل ما
شرحنا ذلك من قبل لقد ذهبنا على القيام
بذلك منذ 30 عاما ستطلق منظمتنا برامج
اخرى وستستمر في تنفيذ برامجها الحاليه
على الارض لسد حاجات الناس لقد مراكز
عنايه من السرطان عندما لم تكن الضفه
الغربيه تتوفر ولو على مركز وحيدا من هذا
النوع لقد بنينا اثنين بفضل تبرعات من
مختلف انحاء العالم بنينا مراكز عنايه
مركزه ومراكز قلب لقد انشانا شبكه من مئات
المتطوعين الطبيين في عام واحد وفي ذلك
العام اطلقنا 150 مهمه طبيه وتمريضيه من
متطوعين من فرنسا والمانيا وامريكا
ونيوزيلان واليابان وغيرها عرب وغير عرب
كلهم ساعدوا الاف الاطفال بظروف صحيه
مختلفه سنستمر في تنميه وتوسيع برامجنا
ومساعده شرائح اكثر من الاطفال وانقاذ
مزيدا من الحوات ونقل مزيدا من الاطفال
للخارج للعلاج بتوحيد جهد الناس فعندما
يكون طفل بحاجه الى المساعده لا يوجد اي
معنى ان تكون فلسطينيا او امريكيا او
اماراتيا نحن كلنا بشر لا يوجد مسلم او
مسيحي عندما يكون هناك طفل يتالم بحاجه
الى عمليه جراحيه او تدخل طبي ينبغي ان
اتذكر دوما اننا كلنا انسان وينبغي ان
نساعد بعضنا البعض باقصى ما يمكن من اللطف
والخير والعطف والحنان وان نعمل على
مداواه بعضنا البعض هذا هو الطريق الوحيد
للبقاء ولحصول الشعب الفلسطيني على حريته
ونحن معكم كل امنيات التوفيق سيد شكرا
جزيلا لك على المشاركه معنا
الى هنا انتهت حلقه اليوم من البعد الاخر
يمكنكم دائما متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما
يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا على العربيه
بودكاست الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]